Trump calls for termination on the
Constitution over Elon Musk Twitter
files leak huffle former president
Donald Trump suggested that the contents
of the leaked warranted a complete
election reader or simply a coup in
which he would be installed as president
a massive fraud of this type and
magnitude allows for determination of
all rules regulations and articles even
those found in the Constitution Trump
wrote on true social and a follow-up he
added unprecedented fraud requires
unprecedented cure in all the certainty
of late 2020 Twitter went to relatively
extreme lengths to deal with the laptop
Story the platform blocked it
sharing a link to the New York Post
story meant your accounts could be
blocked until you deleted it which is
what happened to then White House Press
Secretary Kelly
mccanny whatever her name I'm gonna
eventually get it okay she's old news by
the way uh so this story here with
Constitution what are your thoughts on
this what uh Trump said well I'm not so
much worried about where what Trump said
because obviously Trump has a has a
position here and he's sticking to it
I'm more concerned with what Elon musk's
response was did you see Elon musk's
response where he said no president or
no person is bigger than the
Constitution and I think that's
something that we can all get behind no
yeah no I I agree I agree on that here's
here's what I will tell you
think if you're so you have to look at
this from a couple different
perspectives as an American no the
Constitution is the Constitution okay as
an American if everybody agrees on doing
something with the Constitution from
both sides it's something we ought to
entertain could be something we ought to
entertain
um but at the same time
do think about if you're sitting there
saying I'm telling you guys they did
this I'm telling you and you're like nah
you're an idiot you don't know what
you're talking about you're just a
criminal you're the one that's
manipulating this two years later yeah
everything I said they did they did yeah
but you know who cares just two years
ago nobody really cares about it it's
old story think about how you would feel
as an individual so his understanding
he's just frustrated and just going
going to like his anger yeah he's nuts
right Adam but it's validating his anger
and January 6 I don't give a [ __ ] what
people call it Insurrection the threat
of doing it was a peaceful meeting hold
on hold on hold on bro if let's be real
it was a bunch of dorky ass people
taking photos on Pelosi's desk people
were getting them let in there was FBI
dudes ralling people up let me explain
something bro if you're more I'm not
condoning people getting killed because
I think one one guy had a stroke or
whatever but there's people are more mad
at that than were this is cheating bro
they cheated they stopped stories who
knows what up what else [ __ ] that they
stop I don't give a [ __ ] well January 6
I don't give a shock to be honest you
that's why Pat do you guys think that
that now that whole comedian all that
that smoke is gonna die out now because
guess what he's oh they cheated they
they withheld stories so now it's
validating his anger towards it and
that's all right here's my question too
you're thinking of right now they just
did a recal a re-election whatever all
right guys he's out of the basement this
story is out does he want does he win
the the vote does he win the election
right now today if they started all over
again no covet know what everything no
no I'm just saying no no everyone wants
to play Monday Morning Quarterback and
go back two years and figure out what
happened well I know this Donald Trump
is a toxic candidate I also know that
Joe Biden is a very poor candidate and
in America today we have choices between
shitty candidates okay I'm not a team
I'm not on team blue I'm not on team red
I'm on team red white in blue and this
is the reason why everyone and their
mother is like I don't know Ron DeSantis
I really wish I could I I have I have
very good friends I bring this up all
the time who are as maggoted out as they
come and they're texting me in there
said hey bro I can't continue to be on
the Trump train so I don't know I mean
and who gives a [ __ ] we're not going
back to 2020 as much as Trump truths
about it or tweets about it whatever
they call it a truth she's truthful
we're not going back and at the same
time I understand why people feel angry
things were censored you know big Tech
has a major role in disseminating
information or limiting information so
there's a lot of a lot of people have a
lot of Bones to pick which I totally
understand and I and I empathize with
those people but at the same time it's
20 23 in about 25 days yeah yeah we're
not going back to 2020 I agree it's over
I agree move on I agree and try to clean
it up for 2024. by the way it's we've
had two and a half years to discuss the
hunter Biden laptop and suppressed
though how much did that affect the
midterms not much so well wait a minute
wait a minute you can't say oh it didn't
affect the midterms because this never
came out before the midterm it didn't
come out if this would have come before
the midterms you're saying it's not
going to impact the midterms you know
it's going to impact the midterms the
timing of this was perfect for the left
because this is going to impact
elections zero it's not going to impact
uh midterm and it's not going to impact
2024. it couldn't come out at a better
time for the left period
if I'm a strategic Democratic whatever
uh strategist let's just say for the for
the left I'm sitting there saying guys
relax the worst POS the best possible
time for us the worst possible time for
the Republicans this ain't gonna do
nothing this story is going to move on
in the next two months three months
they're done we're going to move on to
the next thing and we'll find a bunch of
stuff on DeSantis Trump that will make
up and people will buy don't worry about
it so with all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks right if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people were in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hats especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bad toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody body
[Music]